pour les premiers utilisateurs
d'internet c'est ton son inoubliable
celui de l'appareil qui au tournant des
années 90 les connecter au reste du
monde
mais dans les faits la première version
d'internet a vu le jour en 1969
lorsqu'on a pour la première fois relevé
deux ordinateurs d'universités
américaines entre eux aujourd'hui ce
qu'on célèbre céder 50 ans d'arpanet
qu'il résout qu'avec est développé par
le gouvernement américaine l'armée
américaine pour leurs systèmes de
communication à l'époque de la guerre
froide
voici quelques dates clés après arpanet
il ya eu les créations du protocole http
la naissance officielle du web puis
l'arrivée du moteur de recherche google
est bien sur la naissance de facebook
au québec c'est le réseau universitaire
qui tisse la première toile
vingt ans plus tard on parle de lignes
téléphoniques de base qu'on utilisait et
on parle de modem en 89 je crois que
c'était même poids 56 k est aujourd'hui
un 2019 on célèbre no 30 ans et on parle
d'un réseau qui est un multi langues
arts dont la sangha bits par seconde
la demande mondiale explose au milieu
des années 90 lorsqu'une entreprise
privée pour l'autoroute de l'information
au pass deux cent mille sites actifs à
160 millions est aujourd'hui à 2
milliards
le web est maintenant une gigantesque
usine qui tourne sans fin pour produire
de l'information du divertissement et
des controverses
on peut faire la meilleure comme la paix
on peut faire des luttes des
revendications des mobilisations
politiques sur internet on pensait au
mouvement mis tout on pense à i do no
more et on peut également faire le
contraire on peut faire on peut attiser
la haine
le problème cinquante ans après sa
création internet est devenu presque
incontrôlable
il faut légiférer il faut mettre des
cadres faut que les états assume qu'ils
ont le pouvoir de mettre ce cadre là
pour faire respecter la vie privée des
citoyens citoyens le bon côté de la
médaille
avec un réseau de plus en plus
sans et polyvalent tout devient possible
je serais pas surpris que dans dix ans
plutôt que de payer tant aimé quelqu'un
en plus le faire apparaître dans son
salon ou peu importe où on est et la
personne sera là de façon à la graphie
qu'on pourra lui parler comme si vous
étiez là de droit sinon ma grondin radio
canada envers